you know subaru of las vegas the
sponsors of this next segment is all
about spreading love
this time it's through their back to
school clothing and shoe drive
we stopped by to learn more
it starts with the subaru love promise
and that's our commitment to provide
extraordinary customer service but more
than that
to go out into the community and to be
engaged
to be involved well one of the pillars
of the subaru love promise is subaru
loves learning and
we want to make that learning experience
as good as it can be for our youth here
in
in las vegas and so what we've got going
on is we've partnered with helen
jidstrop
elementary school and we have got a
pretty much a dress to impress back to
school
clothes and shoe drive going on it
started
june 18th and it goes all the way
through july 24th
and we're just excited about being able
to support
the families and seeing uh you know good
good clothes being given out to
to these students we chose helen judge
strip elementary school because
74 of the students there are on
either reduced or free lunches and
that's an indicator that there are needs
in the home and that's where we want to
step in
and see what we can do to support the
[Music]
families
i remember going to school uh and
my parents not having a lot and we not
having a lot
and i remember going and putting
cardboard and this wasn't just me it was
my siblings
putting cardboard in the bottom of our
shoes so that we
didn't have those holes and the ground
coming through
i just i have a passion to see families
supported and kids
actually feel feeling good about
themselves and and
being able to go and study and learn and
know that they've got people
that have their back
[Music]
we've got a huge box here at in our
showroom at subaru of las vegas and we
are inviting the public to bring
new or gently used clothes uh
shoes uh and for all ages
because we want to help the whole family
and uh so we're inviting you to bring
that out
uh all the way up until the 24th so on
july 27th that's a tuesday
the families of the students that attend
hell and jed strip
elementary school they get to go between
eight and noon and they can go
there and it's it's called the subaru of
las vegas
closet event and they're going to be
able to pick out clothes and shoes
not just for the students actually for
their entire family
thank you to subaru of las vegas for
sponsoring this segment for
more information call 702-495-2100 or
visit subaru of lasvegas.com
they have a special offer for you now
through july 31st you can get zero
percent apr financing
on select 2021 models for well-qualified
buyers